What's going on Moses?
What do we got in this background?
What we got here is my dad.
This is my dad from from the pet.
Well, that's pillow that's messing it up
'cause I don't have a green...
Solid green screen effects here.
This is the same stuff
they use in Star Wars.
This Dad with hair which
I have never seen before.
Yeah.
This is our dad back in the
eighties before I was born.
He's taking a call and I don't
know who he's talking to,
but whoever he's talking to is like,
Aah, I don't got it!
This is smooth.
He's laying down some
game here on this font.
And that's for people with
lower suit so he's hot.
Absolutely.
He's very hot.
You just went home to visit your parents
but you had to get out of New York.
Yeah.
I was here for three months,
when it was a hot spot.
And then I went down to
Mississippi to get out of New York
just as Mississippi was
becoming a hot spot.
I think you might be spreading this.
You're just as a super spreader.
Either I'm super spreading
or I'm like the tornado chasers of COVID.
Yeah.
Just following that hotspot
with none of the science,
but...
But you're not getting any
useful footage or data.
You're just filming your
parents watching Westerns.
You know...
Yeah, yeah.
You're super spreading.
I'm happy to tell you
to get out of New York
for a while there.
I mean it's...
'Cause New York is not made to
be inside even a little bit.
It's not, but I had to
wait to get tested before
and make sure I was clean before I moved.
So I wouldn't spread and
nothing is more humbling
than realizing you're not famous enough
to get the early tests.
'Cause while Idris Elba
was getting tested,
I was definitely not.
I was like, well, I just
gotta leave it up to the Lord
or whatever you believe in, you know.
Right.
Yeah.
You're a couple projects away from being
cause it's gonna be another
thing with the vaccines.
It's gonna be the elite.
Yeah.
I feel like they just
gonna dangle the vaccine
like above people
and then they gonna have to pick on it
We gotta know someone on the list.
Yeah.
It's gonna be a VIP club of,
get vaccinated baby.
Yeah.
It's not bottle service,
it's vaccine service.
It will just get super drowsy.
But some of the things
it also carries over
but we're all here to
take shots, you know.
What was the test like?
'Cause here in LA you get
tested at Dodger Stadium
and there's so many
people going through that.
You do the test,
you swab it,
it feels all very official
and then you put it in a bag
and then you just literally
throw it into a trashcan.
Which just feels like, how
is this being tested at all?
Yeah, no,
they just stick a really
long swab down up your nose
until your throat,
until your dreams hurt.
And then they pull it out
and then they go do they own thing.
But then the antibodies,
they just take blood like
a vampire or a mosquito.
And that one's easier.
Or a doctor.
Some people say doctors
take blood more often.
Or a doctor or my cousin, Fred.
Cousins taking blood, your
cousins do an antibody test?
And he's in all type of hustles, man.
(laughing)
This is like a side hustle?
So like some antibodies?
I hate the fact that
now I'm just calling people
Yeah.
Like you
and just like running jokes,
trying to run jokes casually
through conversations.
Not to say.
Zoom is our new reality.
The first zoom birthday
party I attended was yours
which was no word, hectic.
Disaster.
It was a beautiful
disaster is what I call it.
You and everyone in your
life that you've ever met
(laughing)
Or should Zoom place capacity?
The most amount of people
you could have on Zoom
attend your birthday party.
Yeah.
So we have people that have
not only never been on Zoom,
but people that have really
never been on the internet.
Yeah.
(laughing)
That's exactly.
Everyone was talking at once.
As soon as I got into the chat,
everybody said happy birthday.
But they said at different times,
so it just echoed for a long time
and children hopped in,
'cause I've got baby cousins
who just liked saying happy birthday.
They don't even know
why they're saying it.
I can't remember who it was,
trying to get everyone
to sing happy birthday at the same time.
But not even knowing which
version, no counting.
They just all just start happy, happy.
♪ Happy birthday ♪
And you can imagine, how
fucking wild that was.
Yeah also happy birthday
is not a great song.
Happy birthday is a song
clearly written by someone
that doesn't wanna sing.
Because it's so many like
you're trying to get other people to sing
♪ Happy birthday ah ah ♪
Just as a sound it's so sad.
No one wants to do it.
It's someone trying to get out of doing it
and get other people to join in.
The happy birthday song is the slow clap
of birthday songs in general.
It's just very much that the whole time.
(clapping)
♪ I'm doing that so I can leave ♪
Aha.
Also my mom definitely did write a sketch
and she got Keenan and Eggo
to play my real parents
that were stating a case on why
they need to have me
come back to the family.
Honestly well written,
well written.
3D level chess type of sketch.
They played with a lot of a time bending
and ultimate timelines
where you were a baby
and that you were adopted
at a certain point.
The sketch had legs.
It truly had legs and it
ran right out of the door.
Oh, somebody we forgot.
My uncle was DJ ing at one point.
While we were trying to talk,
Oh yeah.
(laughing)
He was like
(DJ ing sound)
And then...
(laughing)
You know, it's like everyone
independently was like,
(laughing)
I'm gonna ruin this call.
I'm gonna make sure that no one does it.
I'm gonna bring all my children on.
I'm gonna grill.
I'm gonna try...
And one of my aunts was like,
"Hey, nobody even hearing me,
because nobody can hear me."
Yeah the whole time.
The whole time.
That's all I heard.
You can't hear us.
And then one of our community brothers
looking for somebody to date, she's like,
"I'ma spray you with Lysol."
I'm like, that's not science.
It was a lot going on, man.
It was a lot going on.
It's a quarantine birthday, a must.
Go through it so you experience it.
But, thinking of social change
it's obviously very dangerous
for you to be out at the protest
but it's not like you did nothing.
I mean, you raised a,
what can only be described
as a shit ton of money.
(laughing)
For a protestors that were protesting
that black lives matter.
Yeah.
That might be exposed to COVID
'cause everyone's out there because.
Yeah man 'cause gen Z is crazy
and not taking no for an answer
and not sitting back
and just, you know,
not sitting back and being inactive
and it's a beautiful thing.
And my pops is a high risk so
it was cool to do something
that can support that
while I had to go spend
some time with my folks.
'Cause they elder and I
aint giving them COVID.
I mean, I thought I donated a good amount
and then people have
really donated some amount.
So basically I put a dollar in.
(laughing)
Its crazy.
Is there any part of you that thought
that you would raise that much money?
Not at all, man.
I thought somebody would do a...
Would treat it like jokes
and just steal the idea
and go run and do it a bit
bigger with a bigger group.
Yeah.
Someone's like I know how to do this.
I'm not just some idiot comic
that talks about eating ass on stage.
Yeah.
'Cause like people for this.
(laughing)
People know how to do this.
Yeah.
Take it.
But, man, yeah, it just
sort of built it man.
And and it was awesome to see for sure.
But also it made me really
nervous 'cause I was like,
wait, Oh wait I got to give this away?
How do I do that?
And then
between that moment
and I go like a month of just
nonstop researching on phone calls,
connecting with different organizations,
just kind of learning how
to build a mutual aid fund.
I will say that I created
a job I did not know.
I did not know I was gonna be working
Yeah
but I did it and I'm glad we get to help,
you know what I mean?
But next time I'll like research a little.
A little bit before you hop on.
Yeah 'cause it's a lot of
money to have on your hands.
Yeah I don't like people
playing with my money.
So I this is a lot of money.
I don't want to be playing with it so.
Yeah.
I had to make sure that...
Did you know what the amount is?
'Cause is it still live now?
Yeah.
It's still alive.
It at 364 the last time I checked.
Crazy.
It's insane, man.
It's more than I will make this year so.
Yeah.
You'd be probably getting more anymore.
(laughing)
Really the last thing that we did
that was like a mass gathering
was our show in Chicago.
Yeah.
The NBA all star game.
That's right.
The game and we did a
team Coco house there.
So really the last thing I publicly did,
last irresponsible thing now in hindsight,
was that show in February.
Oh yeah, that was February.
But that was February...
That was like around the time when like
we didn't know it was a pandemic yet.
It was just like...
Just scientists and educated people knew.
But all of us,
(laughing)
Had no idea.
It was Valentine's day.
That's when we did the show.
We did the most ill-advised show.
No but it wasn't the pandemic levels yet.
It wasn't pandemic until like March 9th,
because I also made a joke on AskChanel
that said, "Black people
can't get the corona virus."
How wrong was I?
Oh boy.
That joke...
I can't wait to put up that footage.
I've been looking to
cancel you for a long time.
Ay man, I've been
looking to cancel myself.
So we did that show was on Valentine's day
so we had this preplanned bit of like,
let's talk to the crowd
about dating advice.
And then something happened
where you became very newly single.
Yeah.
In a short amount of time.
(laughing)
So then we had to give dating
advice to people on stage.
I was at a very happy
relationship, still am.
And then you were
a broken.
Fresh.
Yeah, yeah.
Fresh out of a relationship broken up with
over text message.
So it was a...
I was in a raw...
To say raw would be an understatement
but perfectly stated the same time.
Real rough spot.
It's like it happened that day.
Yeah.
That's how I kind of felt.
Some of your advice to the
crowd if I remember was
"I don't know man, just hold onto her."
(laughing)
I think the last joke I said
was just a tear falling onto the stage.
How fitting for the times.
Bobby was saying you called it.
I did.